I would like to talk to you about a very special group of animals.
There are 10,000 species of birds in the world.
Vultures are amongst the most threatened group of birds.
When you see a vulture like this, the first thing that comes to your mind is,...
...these are disgusting, ugly, greedy creatures that are just after your flesh,...
...associated with politicians.
I want to change that perception.
I want to change those feelings you have for these birds...
...because they need our sympathy.
They really do...
...and I'll tell you why.
First of all, why do they have such a bad press?
When Charles Darwin went across the Atlantic in 1832 on the Beagle,...
...he saw the turkey vulture, and he said,...
..."These are disgusting birds with bald scarlet heads...
...that are formed to revel in putridity."
You could not get a worse insult, and that from Charles Darwin.
You know, he changed his mind when he came back, and I'll tell you why.
They've also been associated with Disney,...
...personified as goofy, dumb, stupid characters.
More recently, if you've been following the Kenyan press,...
...these are the attributes that they associated the Kenyan MPs with,...
...but I want to challenge that.
I want to challenge that.
Do you know why?
Because MPs do not keep the environment clean.
MPs do not help to prevent the spread of diseases.
They are hardly monogamous.
They are far from being extinct.
And my favorite is, vultures are better-looking.
So, there are two types of vultures in this planet.
There are the New World vultures that are mainly found in the Americas...
...like the condors and the caracaras,...
...and then the Old World vultures, where we have 16 species.
From these 16, 11 of them are facing a high risk of extinction.
So, why are vultures important?
First of all, they provide vital ecological services.
They clean up.
They're our natural garbage collectors.
They clean up carcasses right to the bone.
They help to kill all the bacteria.
They help absorb anthrax that would otherwise spread...
...and cause huge livestock losses and diseases in other animals.